ah
el momento de hablar de economía en
frases 24 pero yo le dé la bienvenida de
compañera daniela blandón daniela vamos
a hablar de inflación porque los precios
de los bienes básicos se han disparado
en varios países del continente
americano como consecuencia de la
pandemia cuéntenos hola atrás pues
primero recordar para quienes no están
muy familiarizados con el tema que la
inflación mide la rapidez con la que
suben los precios de bienes y servicios
a lo largo de cierto tiempo y a raíz de
la pandemia hoy las cosas cuestan más de
lo que hace un año ahora las autoridades
se enfrentan a un dilema si estimular la
economía con tasas bajas de interés para
que aumenta el consumo y se mueva más la
economía o reducir esos estímulos para
que no se dispare la inflación
consultamos con un analista primero
porque los precios han subido tanto en
el último tenemos un efecto que es
temporal y tal vez el riesgo de que se
convierta en un proceso inflacionario
la razón de la temporalidad tiene que
ver con las disrupciones a toda la
cadena de valor
a la producción el efecto del
confinamiento que ha creado escasez es
puntuales en varias partes y en varios
sectores de la economía incluyendo del
mercado de trabajo el resultado son unas
elevaciones de precios en algunos casos
inesperadas y en algunos casos
bienvenidas porque el mundo avanzado en
particular había tenido una inflación
demasiado baja y el riesgo de deflación
entonces hasta cierto punto que los el
ritmo de crecimiento de los precios
venga a un ritmo normal la gente no se
asusta mucho
daniela diosque en eeuu se ha disparado
la inflación y eso afectaría a varios
países cómo es esto si andrés pues los
precios al consumidor en general
estuvieron 5,4 por ciento en julio más
altos que hace un año en este país una
de las razones es que los estímulos a
los hogares entregados por el gobierno
avivaron la demanda de bienes y
servicios y de paso los precios pues
hagamos una comparación entre febrero de
2020 y julio de 2021 en este grupo de
los que suben están las rentas de carros
la gasolina y los carros usados entre
otros esto último por las clases de
chips que impidió la fabricación de
muchos autos y llevo a la gente a irse
por el usado pero hay bienes andrés y
servicios que han bajado por ejemplo la
ropa de hombre y de mujeres así como las
tarifas aéreas porque pues nadie estaba
viajando y esto afecta a las otras
economías porque la reserva federal se
tiene que ver abocada pues a subir las
tasas de interés cuéntanos cuál es la
situación en américa latina por ejemplo
nos mire una situación o una inflación
elevada sostenida andrés puede ser
perjudicial para la economía porque los
salarios no suelen mantener el mismo
ritmo de aumento y eso significa perder
poder adquisitivo que es lo que está
pasando en américa latina pues en la
región los precios se han disparado más
que en eeuu inclusive la comparación es
interanual a agosto es decir frente al
mismo mes del año pasado lidera
venezuela que tiene una inflación del
1700 por ciento un poco más según el
observatorio venezolano de finanzas
argentinas acumula un alza superior al
50 por ciento brasil tiene el registro
más alto desde febrero de 2016 mientras
que en mexico chile honduras y colombia
los precios no han subido tanto como en
otras naciones pero si se alejan de las
previsiones y eso cómo afecta el
bolsillo pues escuchamos lo que nos dijo
nuestro analista en general la inflación
es un impuesto muy regresivo porque
carcome el poder adquisitivo de aquellos
que dependen de ingresos salariales
aquellas para aquellas partes de la
población los segmentos de la población
cuyos ingresos vienen en gran medida a
través de sus inversiones en el mercado
de capitales ver la bolsa de valores
etcétera tienen retornos que típicamente
están protegidos contra la inflación o
están mejor protegidos contra la
inflación sin embargo aquellas personas
que viven de un salario relativamente
modesto la inflación carcome el poder
adquisitivo de esos ingresos de una
manera bastante
dura y en ese sentido la inflación puede
ser muy regresiva
y además tiene el efecto de que si la
inflación se empieza a salir de las
manos
crea demasiado ruido es como que crean
nubes
o neblina en el sistema de precios lo
que hace que la asignación de recursos y
la producción se se vea dificultada o
que la inversión no sea tan fuerte como
sería y daniela cuál es nuestra cifra
del día andrés en lugar de cifra le
tengo dos ejemplos y le pareció un carro
usado que en febrero del año pasado
costaba 10 mil dólares en eeuu hoy vale
14 mil quinientos ochenta y un boleto de
400 dólares antes de pandemia puede
estar sobre los 368 ahí es como podemos
ver cómo interactúa la inflación en el
bolsillo de la gente esos eeuu américa
latina también es igual daniela muchas
gracias por la formación económica quien
tras 24 y ustedes también muchas gracias
por sintonizarnos quédense con nosotros
[Música]